. I'm going to go next to James from New York.
James from New York.
You were on with me.
What's what's going on in New York these days?
James from New York.
You're on.
Oh, that's you.
Hey, you can hear me.
Yes, I can.
David.
Hi, yeah, my name is James.
I'm actually an E.R. doctor who just graduated
out of New York City.
Great.
I've got a question for you.
I'm wondering sort of all of these different
issues.
Abortion rights, gay rights.
Build the wall.
Any sort of issue like this?
I almost feel like we're sort of missing the
forest for the trees in the idea that, like,
unless we get money out of politics, register
everybody in the country to vote.
It sort of seems like this system is going
to continue to stay broken and that there
is no way that we can fix it unless we fix
these sort of like the Electoral College money
in politics.
Absolutely correct.
Yeah.
So I've said for a while that whatever you
care about, whether it's abortion, education,
whatever your issue is, gay rights, tax rates
or, you know, whatever the case may be, there's
a package of Medda issues that need to be
dealt with.
It's a more systemic issue that includes money
in politics and combined with money in politics.
It's the way media operates, which is very
much influenced by money in politics.
We have to deal with how elections are done.
So we're talking about, you know, electoral
college is a problem.
Fifty five percent voter turnout in presidential
elections is a problem.
That's a really big first past.
The post is a problem.
Got to deal with that.
And the number three climate climate actually
is a meta issue a lot of people don't consider.
But if your city is under water or you're
in the hospital because of the pollution in
your city, it's hard to be an activist when
that is.
Is this the situation in terms of climate?
And honestly, even though health care is a
political issue, if you don't have health
care and you're sick, it's also going to be
hard to be an activist.
So those are kind of like the four meta issues
that if we really want to fix things, you
have to deal with your spot on.
Yeah, it sort of seems like it's a beautiful
system that has been created to sort of basically
distract the everyday voter from these generalized
problems and just get them focused on.
Oh, well, everyone else is lazy or, you know,
you need to just man up and get over your
issues and that.
No, but it's almost like the rats fighting
over the scraps while the one percent just
convinced basically convinces conservatives
to vote for rich people keeping their money.
Yeah, a lot of times what what I recommend
to people is when you're in you're embroiled
in a plot, you're thinking about a political
issue or you're embroiled in a political debate.
Ask yourself whether you're even debating
the right question.
So, for example, the debate over to what degree
can people pull themselves up by their bootstraps?
It's a ridiculous debate.
We know the answers.
We have data on class mobility.
We have data on the impact of not having,
you know, having hunger or of not having health
care and and the effect that this has on class
mobility.
It's the wrong debate.
And it might be fun for, you know, people
who go and speak at colleges and argue with
college kids or whatever the case may be.
But we know that these Medda issues are an
impediment to solving any of these problems
when it comes right down to it.
So I guess my question is, how do we solve
this, like really like how do we even fix
this country?
I mean, as a starting point, if we don't actually
get competent leadership controlling the White
House, the House and the Senate and most of
the governors mansions for at least four years
and make some progress, it's going to be very
difficult.
And that's, again, the system is meant to
perpetuate itself.
It's almost it's almost like a natural selection.
In a sense, the system survives because it's
most likely to perpetuate itself and it perpetuates
itself because it survives.
It's a circle.
Yeah.
I couldn't agree more.
I have all these conversations with different
people of different sort of socioeconomic
and racial backgrounds.
And it just seems like emotion takes over.
No real rational discussions take place.
It's like your political party is your team,
right?
Ford not actually.
Is this benefitting you?
And I just I like honest to God, I'm really
in fear on November and they have this election.
And Trump's going to declare victory.
And what is, you know, 50 million people or
whatever who voted for them?
What do you do when your president says, I've
won?
And if they try and take it from me, you need
to take to the streets.
That's that.
That's my fear.
Exactly.
Listen, before I let you go as an E.R. doctor,
what is going on in E.R. is at this point,
what are you seeing?
So it's it sort of depends on where you are.
But at least in the around the New York City
area, cases are starting to spike again.
Yeah, it seems like I don't want to say, you
know, you know, single out of a single group,
but it seems like it's religious gatherings
and it's nursing homes and they're just sort
of let relaxing standards.
And the numbers are especially around the
city.
They're starting to rise.
And we are either everybody who got super
sick already got sick, and we're going to
be OK or we're gonna do the same thing we
did back in March and April.
And I don't know how health care workers and
the general populace.
I don't know how we get through it if we do
the same thing that happened back in March.
So when you tell someone, hey, you have coronavirus,
are are people surprised in the sense that
they're not connecting their actions to getting
the virus?
Well, yeah, sort of.
It's also difficult just explaining to people
in general that because the prevalence of
this virus is so low that a negative test
doesn't mean anything.
You could have five negative tests and you
could still have the virus that's just based
on data like statistics with the prevalence
being so low.
It's just hard because it's also matters how
you do the test.
And a lot of.
Health care, people don't want to shove that
slob super deep up the nose.
So it's a negative test.
But maybe it's really not negative.
Yeah, it's.
And, you know, we still have a lot of the
tests and a lot of these hospitals are taking
six hours to come back.
Right.
You got sitting in the E.R. for six hours.
It's I mean, it's almost as if everything
we went through in March changed nothing about
how we're handling it right from your ship
in the hospitals to the statewide to the national
level.
It's really scary, to be honest with you.
Hey, last thing I got to run are you're in
the E.R.
You're not actually doing any coronavirus
treatment, right?
Like the end.
If people are getting anything from random
severe to dexamethasone or anything like that.
That's once they've been admitted.
Well, so usually what happens is if we suspect
and they look bad, we'll start a couple of
these treatments.
But if they're looking okay, you just swab
them, make sure there's no other pneumonia
or other sort of infection.
And then you just send them home with quarantine
precaution.
Oh, I see.
Yeah, but it's sort of hard to say.
I know the steroids help, but it's usually
only sicker people.
But the ones that sort of look sick were throwing
the Mac truck at them because we really don't
know what this virus does.
Yeah.
All right.
James from New York, I appreciate you talking
to us today.
It's a pleasure.
Thanks for having me on.
There's James from New York.
E.R. doctor, we're going to take a quick break.
If you are holding, don't hang up, because
we will go right back to the phones momentarily.